hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in his piece the subject in power where
michel foucault is providing us with not
only an analysis of power relations
coming at it from a number of different
angles but also an insight into his own
ways of thinking about this and why he's
doing research in the modes that he's
doing there's a section
which is entitled how is power exercised
and he says for some people asking
questions about the how of power and
then he immediately goes into what
assumptions he's not making that they
are making and a little bit later he'll
say how not in the sense of how does it
manifest itself but how is it exercised
and what happens when individuals exert
as we say
power over others so this emphasis on
the how
of power is really central to foucault's
conception and analysis of power
relations as it's going to turn out
power relations in order to study them
you have to also study other things that
they are connected with
and never completely separate from
but are not also simply reducible to
so why shift to the how and he says my
goal in doing this is not to eliminate
two other questions the
what or the why the what which would be
more of a definitional
classificational question you might say
or a ontological or metaphysical
question about the very nature of power
itself
the why is a teleological
question that could be about you know
class motives or
why are some people mean and and you
know exerting power over others and
others are just subject to them you know
it could there could be all sorts of
ways of understanding this teleology so
why shift to analyzing the
how foucault says some people might be
kind of worried about that
it would mean limiting yourself to
describing power's effects without ever
relating those effects to causes or a
basic nature which would make this power
a mysterious substance one avoids
interrogating in itself
no doubt because one prefers not to call
it into question right and this this
raises a kind of fatalism and then he
says you know
when people have that point of view
they're making a really big assumption
what is that big assumption
power is something that exists
with its own distinct origin basic
nature
and manifestations
and that's a big assumption he thinks
there isn't an essence to power there
isn't a
single capital p power out there that
all other powers are a participation in
he says that we're not introducing a
metaphysics or ontology of power that
either we would describe or we wouldn't
describe that would remain you know
underneath the surface and while we do
all of our cool historical analyses he's
saying strictly speaking
maybe there isn't any such thing as
power as such he says i want to
introduce this suspicion and that is
indeed foucault's position there is no
such thing as
power per se
there's all sorts of things that we
connect together as power there is no
one single simple essence of it so you
know this is a good thing to keep in
mind when you hear
bad takes on foucault saying everything
is power he's not saying everything is
power he's super clear that not
everything is power relations in this as
we're going to see
but there couldn't be a capital p power
to reduce everything too there's no
monism here right we're also going to
see another really important uh
realization at the end of this section
as well that has to do with people
misrepresenting foucault
so he says there's three things that we
have to distinguish
and he says these aren't really things
as such right we could uh call we can't
really
separate these off into three separate
domains even these are phenomena these
are
realities that we're concerned with
these are things that are depicted right
that we can uh open up the historical
archive to and so he says
it's first necessary to distinguish
power exerted over things
and gives the ability to modify use
consume or destroy them this is a power
that stems from aptitudes directly
inherent in the body right i mean so
think about your choppers right your
teeth and your capacity to take in
foodstuffs
and you know chomp on it bite it chew it
up you use get different teeth for
different purposes right you got your
little nibble teeth at the front and you
got your chewer teeth at the the end we
call them molars right you got your
incisors that you invite stuff with our
incisors are not particularly great and
then you've got your bicuspids and you
know we've got all sorts of different
kinds of teeth right and then if we want
to continue this metaphor we also have
all sorts of technology that heating
things up putting them in the microwave
is just one of the very common ways of
doing this but we could go all the way
back to using fire
and roasting things or cooking them in
ovens transforming them
changing the chemistry so that we can't
not just you know taste better things
but consume them and digest them more
effectively right and we go on and on
and on with these sorts of things and
foucault likes the term objective
capacities for this he says let us say
here it's a question of capacity what
about power relations
those are different how
he says what characterizes the power we
are analyzing is it brings into play
relations between individuals or between
groups okay so far so good but i mean
this this earlier thing could be matters
of individuals uh relating to each other
you don't think about sexual activity um
use your mouth your your hands other
organs to do certain things to your
partner or partners or whatever is going
on
that's not yet power relations
instead something else has to be
involved he says
let us not deceive ourselves if we speak
of the power
of laws institutions and ideologies if
we speak of structures or mechanisms of
power it is only in so far
as we suppose certain people
exercise
power
over others the term power designates
relationships between partners not a
game with fixed rules but simply an
ensemble of actions that induce others
and follow from each other a little bit
later he's going to tell us that this
has to do
with
getting other people to do things so
it's creating
possibilities in which things can happen
right
it conditions actions of others so
sexuality could in fact be a domain
where objective capacities are involved
but also power relations and they could
be
distinct from though connected with each
other then there's another thing that he
talks about relationships of
communication huco is very attuned to
the fact that language is not all just
power
right
signal sign semiotic linguistic systems
they have their
own you could say
bases and processes that can very often
overlap with power relations you think
about how we talk about people
or you know what we what we portray
and how that can figure into power
relations as well as objective
capacities he's going to give some
examples in a moment but it's also its
own thing he says
these are relationships of communication
that transmit information by means of a
language a system of signs or any other
symbolic medium
no doubt communicating is always a
certain way of acting on another person
or persons but
the production and circulation of
elements of meaning can have as their
objective or as their consequence
certain results in the realm of power
the latter these results are not simply
an aspect of the former
whether or not they pass through systems
of communication power relations have a
their own specific
nature and so he says it's very
important that we don't confuse power
relations relationships of communication
and objective capacities that's not to
say there's three separate domains
nor that there is on the one hand the
field of things of perfected technique
work and the transformation of the real
and on the other that is signs
communication reciprocity and the
production of meaning finally that of
the domination of the means of
constraint of inequality the actions of
men on other men and he says no no
what's what's the reality that we're
dealing with
we have
three types of relationships that in
fact always overlap one another so
that's important they they intersect
they overlap there's places where
it's both power relation and objective
capacities or both power relations and
relationships of communication right
so which also implies maybe there's some
places where it's more objective
capacities in relationships of
communication and less about power
relations as well
so
overlap
and then he goes on and he says
support one another reciprocally right
they they engage with each other
and
[Music]
beyond that
use each other mutually
as a means to an end which is very
interesting because that implies not
only does does power relations
involve the use of objective capacities
or relationships of communication
but also
maybe relationships of communication use
power relations
right or objective capacities the
transformation of things in the
workspace relies on power relations
right and and these two uh objective
capacities and relationships of
communication also
use each other
so he goes on and he says
this coordination between these three
types of relationships is neither
uniform nor constant this is another
reason why we can't just look for power
per se
things change over time we have to be a
little bit more specific a little bit
more
granular we have to actually look at how
things are organized in a particular
society and this is a bit of a side note
foucault's analysis here is also telling
us you can't just like look at theory
from the 1940s
and try to figure out who are the
fascists right now you know or who are
the stalinists right now or take the
book 1984 and map that on to stuff
that's doing terrible
politics and power analysis from a
fukodian perspective because you're not
actually looking at what's in front of
you
and you're defining things in terms of a
template that you're just importing
and trying to impose yourself
onto the present and there's also some
implications perhaps for foucault's own
project which ends in the 1980s for us
in the
you know new millennium
he goes on and he says
in a given society there's no general
type of equilibrium between
goal-directed activities these objective
capacities right
systems of communication and power
relations rather there's diverse forms
diverse places diverse circumstances
but it's not totally
up for grabs then we don't have to like
say oh well every single situation is
different nobody knows anything why not
because they're what he calls blocks
he says there are blocks in which the
adjustment of abilities the resources of
communication and power relations
constitute regulated and concerted
systems and he says take the example of
an educational institution
the disposal of its space the meticulous
regulations that govern its internal
life the different activities organized
there the diverse persons who live there
meet one another each with their own
function their well-defined character
all these things constitute a block of
capacity communication power all three
of these types of relations
activity to ensure learning and the
acquisition of aptitudes or types of
behavior works
via a whole ensemble of regulated
communication he gives examples of these
lessons questions and answers we go on
and on differential marks of the value
of each person
and by means of a whole system of power
processes what are the power processes
he talks about here enclosure
schools have campuses you're stuck on
the campus you can't leave right you're
supposed to be in a given place at a
given time surveillance
hall monitors are example of this right
reward and punishment right grades
uh you know detention
the pure pyramidal hierarchy
who's overseeing who all the way up to
the superintendents
and he says these blocks
constitute what we might call enlarging
a little sense a little the sense of the
word disciplines now this is another
very important foucodian concept that of
the disciplines right sometimes we talk
about academic disciplines and we forget
that in the academic disciplines we have
all this other stuff going on you know
you don't get to be a a philosophy
professor without jumping through all
sorts of hoops most of which are pretty
arbitrary quite frankly but are you know
coordinated by some sort of rationality
we can say that for every other academic
discipline but there's disciplines
running throughout institutions in our
life nursing involves certain
disciplines which involves getting a
degree but then also getting
credentialed and then also working in
the hospital being in the military
involves other things and you notice
that these all connect with each other
right
so
what does disciplining of society
mean this is where we get to something
really quite interesting
what is to be understood by the
disciplining of societies in europe
since the 18th century he says is not of
course that the individuals who are part
of them become more and more obedient
nor that all societies this is very
important
become like barracks schools or prisons
we'll come back to that in a moment
rather it is that an increasingly
controlled more rational and economic
process of adjustment
has been sought between these three
things objective capacities or as he
calls them productive activities
communications networks right
relationships of communications and the
play
of power
relations he says to approach the theme
of power by analysis of how
is to introduce several critical
shifts it's and we're going to talk
about this elsewhere i want to come back
to this point though that is making a
very off-hand thing
what is
besides the everything is power
what are what is the other main
misunderstanding
of foucault that gets turned into memes
in our day
everything's a prison man
foucault right here
is telling you
that
what is to be understood by the
disciplining of societies
is not
that all societies become like barracks
schools or prisons he's not saying
everything's a prison as a matter of
fact to read foucault in that way is to
totally misunderstand
who goes points
it's not just prisons
schools hospitals barracks all these
other things we might even think about
you know the the practices of the
internet at this point and the
organization of corporate america and
the you know derivation of new financial
instruments all of that fits within the
scope of this
it's not just about prisons so
puko thinks it's very important that we
shift our gaze at least for the time
being to the how of power relations
you